hello everybody and welcome to another
Python 3 tutorial video in this video
we're going to continue on whether
standard library modules miniseries of
our Python 3 series here the last video
were talking about OS this video we're
going to be talking about sis or short
for system system is actually quite
interesting you can use this to do any
sort of like system input/output kind of
stuff basically if you're thinking more
like command line argument stuff like
that and really interesting is the Arg V
or V functionality so that's mostly what
I'm interested in showing you guys today
but I'll also be showing you you know
see out and error especially the
differences of those but anyway with
that let's go ahead and get started so
first we're going to need to import sys
and I'm going to show you guys different
like SC air and SC out now a lot of
people ask like what is the difference
of these two things for the most part
there really is no difference they're
very similar um you should just keep SE
air strictly for errors in SC out for
everything else um really SC air is just
unbuffered and there's a couple other
things that we could do it as the st air
specifically but for now we're just
gonna assume they're basically the same
but i'll show you guys them anyways so
at sisty the air dot right and we're
just going to write tests and after you
do st air a good idea to go ahead and do
sista SC d air flush flesh yeah
so we'll say test so we print this out
and you should get output like this so
that like red arrow text that you're
used to seeing if you've ever gotten an
error which I'm sure you have and I'm
going to change this that this is STD
air text like that and then I'll show
you guys now sis CD out dot right and
then we'll say this is SC out texts and
also what you're gonna see is that I'll
show you guys in a second so we'll save
and run that and you get this so you get
this error text and then SC out text is
just that blue text but you see they're
on the same line so what we can do
at the end of all of these you would
kind of want to always add a new line
there that way everything continues on
on the next line so it just kind of
organizes it a little bit for you guys
so no clothes out of that and now we get
to the fun stuff this is RV so just to
show you guys a basic example we could
say print sISTAR V like this and if we
print that we get basically the file
path and this is the path to the file
I'm editing right now just template dot
behind now that basically is just going
to give you the file name okay but what
we can do with this is actually pretty
cool but you can pass arguments into
this Python file using our command line
which means using any other language
basically or you can use the command
line yourself as well but you can use it
for like batch scripts all kinds of
really really cool stuff so anyway or
really communication between PHP and
Python or Perl or Ruby or
whatever language you're trying to use
you can use this to communicate back and
forth and anyway let's go ahead and get
started so sISTAR V is just going to
display all of the arguments um so what
I can do here though is we'll save this
and in fact let me do something over
here is bring this let's just copy and
paste this into this file save so I've
saved that this data to this file here
that's insists and well so we'll come
over here we have cysts and if you hold
your Shift key and right-click on the
folder here that you're in you can open
the command to line there if you're on
Windows anyway I'm not sure if it works
on Linux or not but you can on Windows
and so now we've opened up this file
that looks just like this okay and in
fact I guess we'll leave that input
output text just for kicks for now um so
let me see if I can make this a little
bigger for you guys
cannot just change the font size Wow
okay I guess we'll just stick with this
for now so in here now we can start
passing arguments through here so what
we can do is I've changed the file name
to sis stop hi so if I run the python
sis dot
hi like that it's going to give us our
SD err text SC out text and then it's
giving us our Arg V and our arc V is
just that file name that we just ran
through so our V is basically all the
arguments that you pass through Python
so when we ran Python our first argument
really was that file named sis top hi
right so that's why we gets to stop PI
but we can pass other things through so
we could say Python assist hi um
look at that run that and now we get
this Python list of Syst up high and
then look at that now what I want to do
is let's come back over to Python 3 sis
we'll open that up and this is the one
that we just made so this is the data
that's in this file and let me go ahead
and make this big text too so it's good
to see and see this just print sista arc
V but now we can do some fun stuff with
it so for example what I would do is if
you're going to start using arguments
before you start referencing the
arguments it's a good idea to go ahead
and make a check for that amount of
argument so here let's say we're just
going to have the file name and then one
more argument that we're expecting so
we're going to say if sis or if Len
cysts are V and what this does is just
tells us the length of a list so if you
had 15 elements Len sister ah give you
would be 15 right so if the length of
sista Arg V is greater than 1 so if we
have more than one argument then what we
want to do is let's go ahead and just
print sista Arg V and then one so this
one right the first element is 0 the
second element is called 1 has an idea
one so we'll save that and we'll come
back over here and we're going to do a
pair oh look at that and now what it's
going to do is you see how it printed
out for us
you know that's the error and out and
then it prints us the list but then we
can we can see here that we were able to
actually reference look at that
specifically because that was one of our
argument variables so now just to keep
things clean let's comment all this
stuff out and this out and now instead
of printing that uh what we're going to
say is print it sista RV and actually
let's do float just this top RV plus
five can we get away with this so we'll
say that come back over here and let's
do instead of look at that let's say
five and so we can see that this must be
a string or a number as the argument
that we've passed through and what we
did here is we have to reference that so
try this one more time and now you get
ten point okay so the reason why that
had failed at first is we didn't put the
the ID so we're saying print float the
float version now we could change this
to int and then it wouldn't be a float
but just in case like say you wanted to
do five point six seven or something
like that then it is ten point six seven
cuz we had a five so we can start
manipulating the values that come in to
Python and so we can use this to pass
values from anything right you can do it
either from the command line itself you
can do it like say you're you're writing
something in PHP like for example I use
this kind of stuff to communicate
between PHP and Python because I hate
web design I just hate it I can't do it
and um you say that you have a Django
series but I hate it
anyway um I don't like doing it and so
most of the websites I make for myself I
just use wordpress and wordpress is PHP
and but like for backend stuff I I use
Python
right because pythons language I know
best I don't really like PHP that much
and I like Python so what I'll do is
I'll use this stuff to communicate
between PHP and Python which is
otherwise kind of difficult to do but
you can use this to use Python you can
make a function and you can make that
function argument or the function
parameter rather a sistah argument right
so for example you could say imports is
and now we can come back up here and we
can you know define main and then we can
call it a sista argh
v1 like that and then we could say print
sista our v1 that's just our function
for example and then we go ahead and run
main and really actually what we would
what we'd probably rather do is instead
of this whoops argh and call this argh
like that main sistar v1 we can save
that and we come over to our command
line here and do pythons sista argh or
sis top I rather 5.67 we're going to
print that argument in the main loop we
didn't say that yeah and run it and you
can see here that we've commented out
everything we made this function that
uses that argument we actually passed so
Stark V through that function and then
we get our return which is really just
you know argh or the arc V which is the
same thing we're doing but you can use
it to pass through functions classes
whatever you can use that so you can do
a lot of really really cool things just
with sis RV's so anyway uh hopefully
that was useful for some of you guys a
really interesting topic there are a lot
of hacky things you can do with this
maybe more on that later but I did just
want to cover kind of the basics of that
if anybody has any questions or comments
feel free to leave those in the comment
section below also if you have any
requests feel free to make them
especially if you have a specific
request maybe with sis module or if you
have any other senior library modules
you definitely want to see let me know
anyway that's conclude this video as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all this for the subscriptions and until
next time